can I ask about a completely different
topic
back to the Stevens very interesting
contrast in the beginning between the
style of reading that you have with the
hallowed 400 page novel and the skinMan
plunge mode that most of us are are more
familiar with a lot of literature
professors are in panic about about this
and and yet the book contains a couple
of pieces that suggests to me that we
ought to be paying attention to new
styles of narrative new cultural forms
that are emerging as fascinating piece
about Japanese cell phone novels from
which I learned a lot and my friends who
are gamers tell me that the the gaming
world is getting to the point that
Hollywood has been dominating for work I
mean being able now I think the Holy
Grail get a game designers as I
understand it is to make a game that can
make you cry and I'm told now that this
begin to happen are there are there
examples like these or others you can
think of forms emerging out of the new
technology that maybe down the road
we'll look at and say now there's a
cultural form that has its own literacy
its own logic its own values attached to
it that people who teach literature or
film or other media might want to think
about I think the gaming is a perfect
example of that question you know when
will there be a game that can make you
cry being a Miss prison completely you
know by of people who are immersed in
one kind of literacy looking at another
one in saying Oh games won't really be
great they won't really be hard until
they make me cry like you know
Casablanca did when in fact most gamers
you know who hear this question safe
what you know halo halo is the best get
you know first-person shooter ever made
it's great no we don't I didn't make me
cry I don't want it to cry because
then I won't be able to see the enemy
and you know and they'll kill me so I
mean I think it's a perfect example
right away of cross literacies and and
and the pitfalls that away I mean and
then the the cell phone thing is a great
I mean to further plump for the book
there's some is a wonderful it's a
wonderful piece about these cell phone
novels that young women are writing in
Japan on their cell phones and the kinds
of to go back to your idea of you know
that this is really a new kind of
literacy with continuities to print and
then the changes of the Codex and
everything I mean what happens is the
girls write these these novels and
differently from normal Japanese writing
which goes vertically down the page
these go horizontally as on a cell phone
and so they're starting to upload these
things and the girls that read them are
starting to learn how to read this way
instead of that way and then the thing
is coming full circle where these cell
phone novels are being printed out and
sold as books but when they reproduce
them on the page in the Codex form
they're doing them horizontally and in a
great echo of your point about how these
literacies are actually masking sort of
class identity questions there are these
great quotes from sort of older
sociology professors literature
professors in Japan saying oh my god but
one of these girls going to start to
learn to read vertical novels
universally they've gone horizontal on
us as if this were you know the end of
civilization I think the other thing
about about games that's worth pointing
out is I mean it really showcases the
the difficulty with the word literacy
because you're so close to literature by
using that word and it's not just crying
in games i mean i think one of the big
mistakes people have always made about
games is they keep saying you know when
are they going to really reach that
level of kind of storytelling that might
involve crying or might involve other
kind of emotional responses and effect
really for the most part I think games
are not narrative forms they haven't
have this kind of vestigial layer of
narrative because they feel like they
need to look like
you know movies in some sense but when
you're playing game the kind of your
consciousness is you're playing a game
almost always it's almost never I really
am interested in how this is going to
turn out you know it's not the feeling
of it the feeling of it is I have to
solve this long puzzle I have to get out
how you're all the different factors i
have to think about what i saw in the
last like 30 minutes and my ultimate
objectives are in balancing all these
different resources and what what do I
have and that's not a narrative feeling
you don't sit there in the middle of
Middlemarch going like all right
Dorothea she's got to get to this next
level with Ladislaw and so if she does
this thing it up I dear like I want to
see how it turns out right so it's a
very different kind of a consciousness
and when you when you judge it by the
standards of george eliot it it's not as
good as Middlemarch even the best games
or not as good as Middlemarch but when
you judge it by the standards of kind of
problem solving and navigating complex
paces and managing resources which are
very complex intellectual skills it's
fantastic and it's much better than
though so in in the book that I wrote
about pop culture everything that it's
good for you I kind of started with this
thought experiment which was imagine
what would happen if gains had emerged
first as the as the kind of dominant
form and culture and then 300 years
later books that come along what would
all the kind of you know cultural
conservatives and critics say about this
new form in the book and they would say
this is terrible you know the kids used
to sit there engaged in this complex you
know interaction with their peers
solving very complicated problems
thinking on their own managing resources
coming up with their own endings and
here they are following these linear
narratives foisted upon them by these
authors and you see them in these
libraries sitting around silently
addicted to these weird texts you know
what an awful thing the kids today you
know they used to be camming with other
people and actually very hopeful wait
I actually actually the game was
invented before knowledgeable and in
fact people did make exactly this kind
of plenty enough of people who basically
wasted their time reading books in fact
they still do to death right grow up a
certain people look at um watch are
playing football oh great it builds
character by bread don't be heard don't
ya I was a football star okay to tell
he's not true that action is understood
purely in terms of getting the next
level strategic actions often understood
in terms of larger narrative Alicia
Professor Richard try to make it true to
religious groups just everything I
understand against the verification
veneno narrative infused all sorts of
the action I think I have bad agreed
about this consultation I think that the
game of the video is really the great
form of art that will development but in
order to understand it won't be better
than that's a very shortened version of
a very bold idea aesthetics which is
what makes earthquake right in one
theory of what makes art director is
like sasol mr. is what makes a great is
that it's incredibly pleasurable and it
has a beautiful flow and it has enormous
right this is why a lot of people be
accessible on the shop and another
vision of heart what makes our great
armies that it plays deeply curations
and it truly reaches in and grasps your
emotional language and other areas as
well makes you central and that's the
short version of it already frog if
thats people it becomes great art and it
actually that's a really a debate over
art of which you understand the game now
is being example and now we see it is
online other forms of art that have
these kinds of extra skill meet humanity
relationship promotion but i have every
reason to believe no matter what your
fear is great artists that Gainesville
patient I think another component of
this that comes back into gaming is the
idea that you're participating in
building the narrative together and what
goes on with a whole variety of
different media that we're seeing do
this goes back to the old conversations
that we used to have around hypertext
and what happened here and you know oh
say I love books i have a small
obsession with books and i do to really
weird things with my with my books one I
really like galleys I like galleys
because their unfinished right and I
like the idea that the book could
possibly be imperfect or the day how
could have mistakes I get a real sort of
kick out of finding mistakes i also have
a sort of obsession with getting my book
signed the reason why I like getting my
books signed is because I like being
reminded that the author is alive that
there's a person behind that author and
it's these two things that I do because
the book is always given to you in this
fully finished form where it's all
perfect you have no sense of how it was
made and you have no sense there's a
human behind this and you're not even
supposed to interact for that human
right and you don't you know I've read
Michael Warner spoken like a whole
Michael Warner's book right and then I'm
like oh he's a human hmm weird I get
interact with him mm-hmm and there's
there's something really strange about
that one of the things that you see a
whole variety of this online media is
about is this reminder that the author
is not dead that the author is playing
alongside you whether they're playing
they're building the narrative with you
in the game whether they're the blogger
who's in conversation with you nothing
is finished and there's something really
beautiful
feel about the idea you know we think
about the perpetual beta as being an
obsession of web two point oh well
there's something interesting about the
perpetual beta of writing and literacy
right the idea that the encyclopedia
might never be finished right is kind of
intriguing it really boggles people's
brains right that you know you could
possibly you know consume saw an
encyclopedia that might be editable like
oh gosh no no no no but there's there's
actually something really delightful
about all the ways in which we have to
think about unfinished writing and
unfinished narratives and literacies
that are evolving with all the
participants and what does that mean I
think we're going to see a whole set of
new technologies from the games to the
blogging to all of this which is all
about this unfinished business and you
know secretly we all kind of know that
none of the books that anybody rights
are actually finished it's more when
that when you were required by the
editor to finally turn it over and just
not in love but that's not something
that sort of sold to the public right
it's supposed to be clean and perfect
and we're sickness that we're saying
like let's tear back those covers and
look at the messiness and what you know
unfolds because of it